i think there's a lot of voters out
there who are who have reevaluated maybe
some of how they voted some people just
vote one way or another maybe their
parents were republicans so they were
democrats or whatever now people are
starting to look wait a minute do i want
to be with a party if this guy's the
leader do i want to be a part of a party
that says i don't have a right to earn a
living unless i take boosters every time
fauci tells me to do i want to be a part
do i want to be a part of a party that
doesn't believe we should have control
over our territory and our borders like
you see what's going on in the southern
border and i think a lot of people are
saying you know what that's not for me
so it gives us an opportunity i think to
build a stronger movement here and i
think the southern florida is going to
be absolutely huge to the future of the
state
[Applause]
i moved to this great state six months
ago okay and i gotta tell you as i
opened with you guys have done it right
and it's it's you and it's you and it's
you and it's you and it's everyone in
this room and it's that florida man knew
something that the rest of us had
forgotten or maybe we never knew
and i promise you that i am here to keep
florida florida and i'm also here to
support this guy ladies and gentlemen
governor ron desantis everybody
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening orlando
[Applause]
and again welcome to the state of
florida and uh thank you so if you come
from california we all we do have
reservations when people come
but you're doing it right and so i
really believe a lot of the people that
have come in the last couple years i
think they're making the state more red
not less red so yes
i don't know if you heard right at the
beginning how many of you guys are new
floridians last year or two
wow i mean look at that that is a
beautiful thing i feel i can either ask
you questions or we could just let
people say nice things to you for the
next 40 minutes
what do you think we should do here well
look i think it's your show i'm just
here for the ride but we're excited to
be here and congratulations on the book
man thank you thank you all right
all right so
first off we have to start with the
obvious one
gay
[Applause]
he didn't even flinch
[Music]
nothing nothing
i thought that in this state we can't
say gay there's people outside they're
freaking out they've got bull horns man
what is i mean
did you choose this fight or do you feel
like they they just brought it to you
and you just punched back
no yeah look i mean look i'm i'm
punching back it was interesting when
that bill was going through when the
legislature's in session they're there
for 60 days
and there's a lot of stuff that's going
on i'm not following every little
committee hearing or anything i mean
i've got dozens of priorities and i've
got folks working on so i'm doubt just
doing my job doing other things and
making announcements like we do and the
media
starts badgering me with these slogans
about gay and i'm thinking to myself
okay um this isn't my first rodeo i know
what they're doing they create
narratives and then they try to run with
these narratives so i know they're lying
i don't know how they're lying but i
just know they are so i ask myself what
is going on with this why are they doing
this and then i see and i'm like you've
got to be kidding me are they honestly
going to make this the hill to die on
and so even though it was not
necessarily legislation that i had
authored initially
i started fighting back against them
because they were just lying to people
and it's offensive when they're lying
and
and so we start fighting back and i
would literally have these reporters i'd
say okay where does it say that in the
bill
okay it doesn't say that in the bill
what does it say oh okay so you know and
so it was it was it was good we were
fighting back and then you had this
situation where you had the corporations
mostly disney deciding to get involved
and i think people look at that they're
like first of all i don't know why they
got involved in this it was a huge
mistake for them they think they've lost
60 billion in market cap since they got
involved but what what the left is doing
though it's honestly smart for them
they know that if people knew
that
if they were running for election on
gender ideology for kindergarten first
graders that would not fly with the
voters okay
parents just don't want that for these
young kids and a lot of the elderly in
florida don't even know what the hell
you're talking about so it's not it's
not good and they know they can't win
elections on that so i think what they
what they try to do which is smart they
say okay if we could subcontract out our
leftism to a corporation pressure the
corporation to come on our side then
maybe they can get these elected
officials to cave and you know what it's
not a dumb strategy because there have
been a lot of republican governors that
have caved to corporate pressure you've
had republican governors veto bills just
to protect women's athletics and women's
sports because some of the businesses
got upset so i understood why they were
doing it i thought it was a mistake for
disney to get involved and i told them
you shouldn't get involved it's not
going to work out well for you so they
kind of got involved
i i don't know if you heard what donald
duck's been up to
but
no but the thing is is is you know
they're going to go out and i honestly i
think it's ridiculous when these
corporations do all this stuff but i
mean you're free to do it but when
they're lying and they're accepting
these phony narratives just think what
happened last year when georgia did
their election integrity law you had a
massive hysteria by corporate media by
the left by twitter and all this stuff
you had delta airlines you had coca-cola
demagogue the bill they equated it to
jim crow you had major league baseball
move the all-star game out of atlanta
and so we've now had our first election
in georgia uh earlier or last month
under the new law
record voter turnout and so
they were lying about the georgia bill
anyone who read it would know and so i
think when they're accepting these false
narratives especially if it's about
people in my state that are in the
legislature or whatever we have a
responsibility to fight back but i think
disney took it one step further when
they put out this incredible statement
after they already did all their virtue
signaling after we signed the bill
saying this was somehow a violation of
human rights and
that they would work to see that parents
rights and education were repealed
through the legislature and i'm just
thinking to myself
you know i took an oath to support the
laws and constitution of the u.s and the
state of florida i did not
take an oath to subcontract out my
leadership to a corporation based in
burbank california they don't run this
state
and so
but again they are free to do that i
think for a publicly traded corporation
i think it's stupid and so i think that
you're gonna have a situation all right
butt out nobody wants to hear from you
nobody wants to hear from you get out of
here
[Applause]
got plenty of friends for you across the
street my man
so they they get in they're gonna they
commit themselves to this really
ridiculous uh course of action
and they're free to do that it's not
smart as a publicly trade but you are
free to do that
but they are not free to force all of us
to subsidize their activism and that's
what they were doing
they have their own government or they
did have their own government right here
they're exempt from laws they get
massive tax breaks and so you know if
their company is committed to that view
of what's appropriate for children and
parents uh as the state we just can't
have a partnership with that and so
we're out and that's why we took action
to dissolve their own government
[Applause]
so
so i know we could do we could do
politics all day long and i do politics
for a living and these guys they're into
politics but there's something else
going on here i think that that you
exemplify which is just one man against
the system that you just said no and i
want to know just on a personal level
not at a political level where do you
think that came from within you was that
something that you always had i mean
when the covet stuff was happening and
everybody else locked down everybody
else followed fouchy every you said no i
mean that's all you you just said no and
i wonder where did that really come from
within you
well look i think that there are people
that that get involved in in elected
office who
uh are there to be able to enjoy the
accoutrements of office to be able to
have a title
and then there are people that get in
because they actually want to do
something and they also want to make a
difference so i'm the latter
and
[Applause]
when i became
governor i remember going into the
office for the first time sitting in the
chair and i said um you know what
i don't know what sob is gonna end up
succeeding me in in eight years but i
can tell you this
there ain't going to be any meat left on
the bone for them because i'm going to
take on issues i'm going to be on
offense i'm not just going to sit back
i'm going to make sure that we're really
making a difference but i would do it
based on what i thought was right
and i have not taken a poll since i've
been governor i'm not trying to react to
whatever some of you know random burst
of opinion my view is is when you lead
if you set out the vision and you
execute the vision and you do well
people will follow that and that's what
they want to see and so
that was just my philosophy
and so when it came for like covid you
know i remember like you know just
getting hammered by corporate press and
they politicized it they wanted to use
it to take out trump they wanted to use
it to take out people like me and that's
just what they do
but you know my view was okay if by me
protecting the jobs of all the people i
represent
ends up putting my own job in jeopardy
then so be it let the chips fall where
they may
i wasn't worried about politics
and i would totally be willing to um
because i look i have there's great
there's a lot of opportunities in life i
didn't like i have to to do this and so
if it didn't work out for me i would
have been totally great being able to
look in the mirror and say you know what
i did what i thought was right to
benefit the people i represent i think
when you get in situations where some of
these politicians you know they get
paralyzed by polls and consultants and
everything and then they
don't do what they think and their guts
right because they're worried about
blowback they're worried about the media
they're worried about political
consequences well then guess what
happens you end up not succeeding most
of the time anyways then you end up
looking in the mirror like man i just
wish i would have followed what i
believed in and so you know no regrets
you got to do what you think is right
and in this case with florida
i
you know with kovid
i actually consumed the data myself i
didn't just i wasn't just you know
saying if fauci says something then you
got a genuflect what are they getting at
the data and the fact is fauci was wrong
about a lot of this stuff
okay
we were the first big state to guarantee
every parent the ability to send their
kid to school in person way back in 2020
right
fauci opposed us having kids in school
he opposed what we were doing when we
had businesses open and protecting
people's jobs and we're having these
events he opposed us every step of the
way and so that wasn't based on data
because the schooling was obvious that
you needed to have the kids in school it
was based more on ideology and it was
more based on all these other things so
we were right to have to stand up to
fouchy
we'll respect your free speech if you
respect ours but you gotta do it outside
you gotta do it outside so at the end of
the day that's just my philosophy and i
would just i think that you gotta do
what you think is right i i tend to you
know if there's a choice between going
against the machine and siding with the
folks i'm gonna side with the folks and
here's the thing i think that
i think people get it more than they
ever have they understand you look at
some of these elite bureaucrats like
fauci you look at the corporate media
big tech the emperor has no clothes
these are discredited elites in our
country and they don't have your best
interests at heart
they don't have this state's best
interests at heart
sometimes though it doesn't feel like
you know your voice can be heard because
so much of it is dominated by this one
viewpoint but when you stand up and you
stand in that fire and you fight back
for people man they will have your back
they will support you and that's what
we've shown in the state of florida
[Applause]
see
he doesn't like polls but standing
ovations ain't bad you know
those are pretty good i got an idea so
you know if you weren't a politician
well how about this maybe and you guys
could chime in on this we don't have to
put the governor on the spot but maybe
like you know you crush it in this next
election here in florida let's do maybe
eight years in the white house and then
you become ceo of disney how does that
sound
[Music]
who knows what happens you never know in
life so
all right so so let's talk about some of
the other stuff that you're doing
because you really are doing stuff here
that is not happening in the rest of the
country you just signed this fatherhood
bill last month here this is just
another issue that you took on that
seemingly we need to talk about we don't
talk about honestly and you chose to to
fight it so tell me a little bit about
that
yeah i mean i think that if you look at
what's going on in our in our society
um
[Applause]
did they have to at least pay to get in
here okay good good
i mean like look i get people have their
shtick i get people you know do things a
little bit different on that side than
than we would but honestly it's so
ineffective no but all you do is tick
people off when you you try to interrupt
these events so keep doing it you're
just going to help us in the long run um
but
and you live in florida
florida
people but you know the fatherhood is is
interesting because if you look at
all the different problems society could
deal with uh a huge number of them are
rooted in
kids growing up without having a father
in the home and
so i started getting involved in this
when i was my first year as governor
we're doing the budget there was some
money for a group called all pro dads
and it was founded by former bucks and
colts head coach tony dungy who's a
great guy and and tony
and you know look i just signed next
year's budget i vetoed
a world florida record 3.1 billion
before i became governor the record was
like 800 million and so we're we're very
tough and i mean we will veto and so you
can veto individual items and so he
called me just to kind of like make the
pitch and you know i'm like honestly um
i trust you i know you're gonna your
heart's in the right place and i know
this is important so we started getting
involved we'd work with private groups
we'd work with our state agencies and
then this year kind of a more
comprehensive thing but if you talk to
coach dungey and he was at the bill
signing when he said when he became
tampa bay head coach he went to minister
at some of the prisons and he looked and
he said you know i noticed that it
wasn't because of poverty race all these
other things the reason these people
were in prison was because they did not
have a father figure in the home and if
you could address that you would have so
much better
luck in society overall so that's what
we're trying to do and part of it is
resources education part of it though is
sending a message to men
meet your responsibilities
you have a responsibility
[Applause]
and i can tell you
[Music]
you know one of the reasons i ran for
governor i was a member of congress for
a few terms and i first got elected it
was just my wife and me second election
it was just my wife and me well then
after the third election 2016
we had our first child our daughter
madison and so i'm in dc thinking to
myself you travel back and forth i'm
like why am i up here you know i really
want to be back home and so as with
governor you know we see him every day
uh we're able to be present and i'm very
busy i'm much busier in this job than a
congressman would be
but because we're all in the same state
on the you know obviously living in
tallahassee now uh you're able to do it
so my wife and i put a lot of emphasis
on that but particularly me they're
they're just you know my wife does some
great things that i don't do as good in
but i offer just something else in terms
of in terms of uh work for the kids to
look up to so i think it's essential and
i've said if we could snap our fingers
every kid grows up in america with a
with a good father in the home we would
not be talking about a lot of these
other problems no way
[Applause]
so as a new floridian one of the things
that's constantly on my mind is what can
i do for this state and i really mean
that what can i do for this state that i
i feel like a refugee i am a refugee it
it
i genuinely feel like i came from
another country and thank god you guys
speak english here that's basically
that's basically where i'm at but so
what do we do what do we do to defend
florida because the more that florida
does it right the more that the machine
whether that's the media or the
political machine or just the elite
machine whatever you want to call it the
more it is going to stare down you stare
down these folks what do we do to just
keep this state right
well i think it's a great question
before i answer just let me say this
about california so
um first time you got to put money in
the jar man that's the deal
so covet hits
first time i went to california since
covid was june of
2021. so over a year into covid but you
know they still hadn't met they had it
was not like florida so i so i'm out
there doing stuff like fun all this
stuff and i told myself i'm like look
i'm not wearing a mask
i'm going to do my thing so you put me
wherever you want to put me but just
understand i don't want any
confrontation or anything but this is
i'm going to live like i live in florida
so i get there first day i'm there i'm
waiting the cars are coming to pick me
up i'm on the curb these two guys in
mass come scurrying over to me i'm like
oh god here we go
one guy gets right in front of me pulls
down his mask looks me right in the eye
and says i wish you were our governor
put on the mask and left so
you never know
and so it was interesting
um
but what i would say is
when you're looking at
big time fail buddy big time fail
[Applause]
you know part of what we're doing i
think now is
we've been able to create so much
momentum
that like 2018 election very close call
for the state of florida when i got
elected because if i had not gotten
elected many of you none of you who
moved here would have moved here and
some of you that lived here probably
would have moved away
just the truth
but
when i got elected we had almost 300 000
more registered democrats in the state
of florida than republicans and we never
had more registered republicans in
florida prior to me becoming governor
well
negative 300 000 november of 2018 june
1st 2022 we have 150 000 more registered
republicans
now
so i i think that that is uh telling us
that we have an opportunity uh to really
solidify the direction that the state's
going uh this november and so i would
say you know my election very important
and we just need a massive turnout and i
think we can get it you know people will
come up to me who you can tell are not
super political and they'll thank me for
saving their job they'll thank me for
saving their kids education they'll
thank me for saving their business and
they want to be helpful so we have an
opportunity to do that and i think that
that's absolutely critical but i also
think yeah we've got a lot of great
people that have moved in here i mean
you look at like you know down in miami
you know miami is like this i mean first
of all it's never boom the way it's
booming but it's moving right and there
aren't very many urban environments in
this country that are really moving
right and you know part of it is the is
the demographics i mean you know you
look at like our hispanic communities
there are conservative and they want to
make sure that this country doesn't
repeat the mistakes of these other
countries in latin america where you had
marxism take over cuba venezuela all
these other places and so i think
particularly with you guys in south
florida because it used to be
south florida would be like huge blue
you know then you'd have pockets of blue
orlando gainesville whatever and the
rest would either be really red or maybe
kind of purple and now south florida is
becoming much more conservative and i
think that that's largely i think it's
true i do think it's a result of the
migration and i think it's a reaction
against brandon's policies which let's
be honest
have not been terribly successful
you know i did the budget thing today we
were at the villages and i and i just
point out there's news reports recent
news reports he's so frustrated that his
approval ratings are in the toilet and
he's lashing out at his staff blaming
this blaming that and i'm just thinking
to myself you have a situation where
you know you came in
and oh by the way for for any more of
those people that are out here we're not
going to let them take away your
constitutional rights
not going to happen
but but you have so so but brandon he's
lashing out blaming other people and i'm
just thinking to myself man
you want to know why your approval
ratings are in the toilet look in the
mirror
your policies are failing people don't
want to pay
475 a gallon for gas and it's gonna be
over five dollars very soon they don't
want a war against domestic american
energy you know for some reason with
biden if you beg maduro for oil that's
somehow not global warming but if we
produce our own then it's global warming
give me a break what a farce and so
he's creating a lot of these problems
and here's the here i mean i'd say
between brandon and and
i think there's a lot of voters out
there who are who have re-evaluated
maybe some of how they voted some people
just vote one way or another maybe their
parents were republicans so they were
democrats or whatever now people are
starting to look wait a minute do i want
to be with a party if this guy's the
leader do i want to be a part of a party
that says i don't have a right to earn a
living unless i take boosters every time
fauci tells me to do i want to be a part
do i want to be a part of a party that
doesn't believe we should have control
over our territory and our borders like
you see what's going on in the southern
border and i think a lot of people are
saying you know what that's not for me
so it gives us an opportunity i think to
build a stronger movement here and i
think the southern florida is going to
be absolutely huge to the future of the
state
[Applause]
well first i just want to say that i
love that you keep calling him brandon
because
i think it's possible he thinks his name
is brandon
so that's pretty beautiful also i wasn't
going to do this the end we only have
one more quest time for one more
question but i wanted to give you a
let's go brandon t-shirt it seems
that he should put it on right now and
rip it off hulk hogan style
[Applause]
all right one more for you
sort of on that bravery thing that we
talked about before and where that comes
from within you and all these people
that are out here and as we watch this
thing happen and watch the media come
after you and all of that stuff
what else can they do to fight what else
can they do what can empower them to
just be part of this thing and keep this
state right keep this country right and
go on well one of the things the points
i'll make and obviously i mention
biden's failures a lot
and relative and deservedly so but
here's the thing
i could deal with that if in exchange i
could have a conservative majority on
every school board in america for
example
[Applause]
what you can do at the local level
uh to really be involved in your
community particularly with these
schools because i think that we've led a
lot at the state level you know making
sure that that obviously the young kids
you know aren't having the sexuality
involved in the gender ideology also
making sure uh that we don't have things
like critical race theory and all these
ideologies and that's important
but really it's the parents and the
people that are running for school board
and all these other things and so yes i
obviously made a plug for my election i
think it's very important but i think
the school board elections have more
importance than ever before
you guys can make a huge difference in
your community and you know the moms
have done great and the parents are
energized like never before and they
should be really leading the effort but
you know what you don't even have to
have kids in the school system to be
concerned about what's going on with
education because if you
if we do our job right and we're doing
you know good solid education i think
you need to have things like we've
pushed in florida american civics
understanding the constitution
understanding all those things
if we're providing a solid foundation
for education rather than having these
systems become centers of indoctrination
you are going to be we are going to be
so much better off as a state than a lot
of these other places and so i would
just say
get involved in some of these local
races get involved in some of these
local organizations because you really
can move the needle i mean the the enemy
really in some respects yes the left but
also just being apathetic
because when we're apathetic then the
left is able to capitalize off that so i
think those days are over i think we
realize that you know we're in a fight
to ensure the survival of liberty and
opportunity for not only ourselves our
kids but even generations yet unborn and
so you know now's the time to saddle up
and get it done and so i would love to
see
yes big red wave people will focus on my
race some of these other races but i
would love to see a big red wave sweep
these school board races across the
state that'll make a huge difference
well governor i want to thank you for
taking the time to join us here tonight
uh truly by you doing the right thing
my life is better everyone in this
audience their lives are better
and on that note ladies and gentlemen
make some noise for governor ron
desantis everybody
governor ron desantis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen i have been on tour
for two months we thought it was right
to end it in orlando with the governor
you guys have been absolutely awesome
i am telling you i am i am truly the the
proudest new floridian and i thank you
for doing it right i thank you for
watching i thank you for supporting me i
thank you for coming out and fighting
for freedom and laughing at those freaks
and on that note everybody thank you
very much
you guys are awesome
let's go brandon let's keep florida
florida everybody if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell